[Music]
alright guys so y'all know that I've
been doing a fundraiser for masks with
my buddy and I want to make sure that
you guys are also not [ __ ] and you
are making yourself useful but actually
not all jokes aside off-camera
Julia was telling me something about so
my middle sibling works at a hospital
and they're actually running low on
supplies and so they were actually
reaching out to like local places like
local breweries to help them make
alcohol that's crazy little to make hand
sanitizer so people could drink and then
[ __ ] know it's not the same don't
drink those soon as I got back from
Europe that's the first thing I was
looking for alcohol yeah yeah rubbing
alcohol oh not like to drink cuz you're
not on drinking [ __ ] but it was all gone
yeah it was like I don't know some
[ __ ] chemical there I was like that
ain't gonna do [ __ ]
vinegar yeah so like my middle sterling
reached out to me asking if I knew
anyone that had a 3d printer because
they were running low on masks at the
hospice at the hospital and so what they
what they did was that they sent me like
a little blueprint of that 3d print
design that they want in it's basically
like a plastic band that goes like right
across the forehead and then oh yeah so
their ears don't get off look duh yeah
around the forehead and then they'll
happen then you get the shield yeah
uh-huh
they'll have you like the dim sum cart
no no there's this but they're the other
way there's different types there's one
that like goes behind it go like this
right no no it's it's like just think
about as a visor like a welder yeah
yeah I know Naz what other reaching out
to people to make that exact thing and
they're advising people who especially
have the hobby of 3d printing not to try
to change the plans because you know
people are like oh I want to fix it to
make this better this better they're
like no just take what we gave you use
this exact plan make it so that way
because have you change one thing all of
us and all the other things won't fit
right and then the bigger thing is if
people can injection mode that's way
better
oh that's great laughter yeah because of
the 3d printing you can do like one band
per three hours yeah injection molding
you can do a ton so what a lot of people
are doing now is that they're taking
this the 3d printed thing taking it to
the injection motor and then making a
bunch at once yeah so there's a bunch of
people a bunch of youtubers even getting
together and doing this kind of [ __ ]
it's kind of crazy how when [ __ ] hits
the fan you see how people react to this
some people they take advantage of it
because I know like the inner workings
of this whole supply chain [ __ ] like
the more I get into this fundraiser I'm
learning [ __ ] right so like one of one
of it is I'm being accused by some
people that I'm a con because you know
with every fundraiser they go you know
where's the transparency or whatever
right but there's a lot of things that I
can't really say politically because to
protect certain things I had to do some
deals behind the scenes like for example
what I can't is because here's the thing
people that do know right and people
that are in the medical industry or
whatever they know that there aren't
masks and they're like how the [ __ ] are
you getting them well for one is I had
well not me personally but my you these
guys were you're like except from like 6
feet away we had to negotiate literally
with a team of retailers and ask them to
stop selling it to the public oh the
thing is they just listened they were
just like sure well the thing is we're
buying them retail prices not wholesale
prices because we had to make it a
win-win situation because first of all
like they're still a business
and even though hospitals need the masks
they still need to pay their employees
they still need to push numb like they
need to be a business right so for us it
was like okay what I think common people
might be like well they shoulda just
gave it to the hospitals but that's
being irrational like you can't really
say that because everyone needs to eat
so for us we're trying to figure out a
win win situation for everyone so the
the the the solution we came up with was
how about we purchase it for retail
prices so you guys don't lose business
and at the same time buy a wholesale
with control yeah like and then they'll
give us a small discount because we're
buying so much but then we get to give
that and control it to the first
responders like officers like people in
ICU like and the thing is there's
hospitals out there that are stopping
operation because they don't have the
gloves the masks whatever and that's the
that's the crazy part it's not just all
corona related there's people that need
you know surgery or whatever and they
don't have supplies so it's just a crazy
[ __ ] but here's the thing the
retailers are getting [ __ ] too right
now because air cargo they're like damn
dude I'm gonna take advantage of this
like no shipment and everything and
they're charging up the ass so the
wholesalers are getting [ __ ] and they
have to charge more and then the
wholesalers are charging retailers more
so all along the supply chain everyone's
charging more so it's just [ __ ] crazy
yeah pretty much people do that like
they know it especially in a time like
this
their first thing is how do I make money
oh yeah there are two kinds of people
like oh yeah we want to help people
don't need whatever we can the other
ones are like oh man we can make so much
money from this yeah so my friend who
helped print out some of the visors it
did take like two to three hours just to
print one but he's yeah he's able to
maybe like squeeze two per every like
two or three hours but um him meeting up
with my middle siblings like coworker or
whatever was like really funny because
they met up behind a target parking lot
where there's like no one around and
then um the hospital worker pulled up
next to my friend's car door like 6 feet
apart at all times those are like my
deals yeah
I feel like the guy would like go to his
backseat open the backseat goes like
back like just like walks far away from
his car and in my friend gets off his
car drops the plastic visor into his
backseat and then he goes back into his
car and they both acknowledge each other
of that exchange they did one exchange
and then when I asked him how to go he
was like I have another drop-off
tomorrow same time same parking lot I'm
not even going into the hospitals I go
into the parking lot open up my trunk
yeah
and then the doctor or nurse will come
out and I'm like take that box that's it
I did that closes down I don't shake
hands or nothing this might be a stupid
question but it should this I genuinely
don't know why doesn't the hospital buy
directly from said just yes so here's
the problem that it's not the hospitals
that don't have money hospitals have
money they there's not enough supply so
even if they have the money the the they
can't get the supply in time so the
problem is hospitals they have a list of
like you know holes or distributors that
they they can buy from that they're
certainly very specific of what you can
get and and so the thing is like you
know n95 s are just gone or like
whatever so let's say like you
manufactured these right and then so
when as a manufacturer you'll sell to
wholesalers so certain wholesalers are
certified to be bought from from the
hospital and in the hospital they'll
send in their order and then these guys
are already depleted because if they're
if all the clients are like hospitals or
whatever right so the whole problem
started when China got sick cuz then
they stopped manufacturing and when
China got sick and in you know the I ran
in like Europe and they got sick before
us right so they bought up a surge of
medical supplies and then we're kind of
like the last America to get sick right
so like it was already out so China's
back on board now and they're like their
factories are open and they're
manufacturing but there's a month or two
delay so that's where the problem is is
they need hospitals need
supplies yesterday and so what's
happening is that there are Rios a list
here that have supply that aren't
certified but in theory then what's
wrong with going with non-certified
thing well the the hospitals could get
in trouble accepting it now though well
cuz there's a liability issue so so so
so the hospitals not accepting it I'm
giving it to doctors and nurses and
they're passing it out because that
that's that's different because there
are hospitals where they're hoarding
this [ __ ] and the the employees are
saying like where the nurses are what
they're like don't give it to them
because our administrators people are
donating masks and we get the box and
then the administrators just put it in
lock away and then they're giving these
guys one mask a day
oh no yeah because they're like we need
to ration or like these don't meet
requirements so that's there's just so
much [ __ ] that's going on and it's so
complicated
yeah I've seen videos of like medical
professionals and stuff they'll show you
how to save the masks and like reuse it
safely so I'll take it off and then they
put it in like a Tupperware I mean
without the lid and then they leave it
that way so that they can like to put it
on again it it's so much information I
feel like I'm learning so damn much
about every step of the way and how
[ __ ] up our healthcare industry is
because here's the thing like what sucks
is there are sick doctors and nurses
right but there's not enough staff so
they have to work now about how many
retirees are coming back thousands of
people who are retired are coming back
and which is crazy because they retired
so they're also in the high-risk age but
you just need medical professionals one
of our staff members his mom tested
positive for kovat and they still make
her go back in the world so they might
be spreading it and and especially if
you're not wearing the proper protective
gear let's say like you're supposed to
switch these out after every single
patient that you see but if you're
wearing one a [ __ ] day dude like
that's why we're just trying our best to
get it from retailers because so here's
the thing there are whole sellers that
have it but they're not all certified
we're looking
lucky enough that we found FDA and si
approved so it's not the top top level
but at least it's approved by like a
legit
you know organization are you guys
moving volume at the pace that the
retailers are like satisfied with no so
this is the problem is that we're not
moving enough so like luckily what
happened is we met our first goal which
is $15,000 but in the large scale of
things like we're not moving enough mini
so came out and they said they'll match
our donations so that's [ __ ] cool
because yeah that's like 20,000 masks
right there we just surpassed it we're
at $20,000 right now and then yeah so
we're gonna keep pushing the bar but my
buddy is so [ __ ] gangster that what
what he ended up doing is that when the
retailers started complaining like guys
like if we put this online right now we
can sell all of it out right so instead
of doing that he found it was either
FEMA or one of those organizations but
he got them to buy to take a contract of
a million masks so to cover what the
public would buy he just called the
government up and so they're gonna get
that and we're still gonna be able to
piggyback off of that big purchase so we
can still provide to the local hospitals
yeah so we [ __ ] did it like so
there's so many behind the scenes [ __ ]
that's like going on that yeah like it's
just business you know and then I think
at the end of the day like a lot of
we're also trying to protect the
retailers too because they have the
supply and we don't want them to look
bad and at the end of the day like I
don't know man it's it's difficult to
say it's like it's difficult to maneuver
this where no one looks bad
yeah good job yeah thank you link is on
the bottom if you guys want to help we
still need this I think he's like if we
push it hard for a month
that's when China supply should be here
but that's what everyone's kind of
racing to
[Music]
you
[Music]